voilà pour ce documentaire aussi
effrayante éclairant sur la réalité du
régime chinois nous a longuement revenir
sur ce que nous apprennent ces images
ces témoignages comment analyser la
stratégie chinoise de colonisation de
cette province quels sont les intérêts
de la chine dans cette région et
pourquoi cette annexion et la lente
destruction de cette minorité et plus
largement
qu'en est il des droits des minorités en
chine
et pourquoi cette question ne se
trouvent plus le retrouve plus de caisse
de résonance d'un point de vue
international dans les médias ou sur la
scène politique
autant de questions que je vais poser à
mes invités jean luc domenach bonjour
vous êtes directeur de recherche à
sciences po sinologue donc spécialiste
de la chine merci d'être avec nous
stéphane lagarde à côté de vous vous
êtes journaliste rédacteur en chef
adjoint du site asia liste que je
conseille à nos téléspectateurs
vous êtes grand reporter à erie fiez
vous avez vécu quatre ans en chine
merci d'être avec nous enfin je me
tourne vers emmanuel athanasiou vous
êtes militant des droits de l'homme je
bonjour vous êtes l'ancien coordinateur
et fondateur de la campagne
internationale pour lucia hobo et lucia
de dissidents chinois encore emprisonnés
aujourd'hui jean luc domenach je me
tourne vers vous vous avez regardé le
documentaire est ce que ça vous étonne
ce que vous y avez vu non non je sais ce
que sont tout à fait ce que je savais où
on présentait je suis pas un spécialiste
du think tank jeu mais j'y suis allé
notamment une fois assez longuement en
partant du pakistan par la fin le chemin
qui est déclinée plus possible là est ce
que j'ai vu en quelques mots quelques
temps mais beaucoup beaucoup peu inspiré
de colère et est ensuite donc je me suis
un petit peu informés et voilà
c'est un cas tout à fait effroyable
hockey effroyable stéphane lagarde vous
êtes d'accord vous comme vous étiez
correspondant en chine
vous avez pu vous y rendre ou pas we
dance est très difficile c'est plus
facile pour la radio effectivement pour
les pour les visions des pouvoirs donc
c'est extrêmement difficile de tourner
trois qu'il est compliqué effectivement
si en tant que journaliste et s'y
rendent en tant que journaliste
effectivement les suivis tout le temps
alors on y va souvent on y va en train
par exemple aussi moins se faire repérer
par l'avion se fait repérer quand même
au bout d'un moment c'est toujours un
repère et donc on fait très attention à
nos sources est ce qu'on remarque
surtout quand on est journaliste projet
était dans les années 2000 à 2010 2013
jusqu'à 2014
c'est qu'elle est une population
traumatisée qui a très peur c'est
vraiment ce qu'on ressent quand on va en
rencontrer des témoins même quand ils
ont les nous héberge chez eux ils sont
traumatisés ils nous disent la terre
nous écoutent le parti nous écoutent ils
ont été traumatisés par la répression
on a extrêmement c'est très très
difficile d'avoir des des duos du rhône
comme on dit des journalistes
ils sont ils ont vraiment peur tous
d'être arrêté et donc il parle très peu
aux journalistes ça il faut dire que les
ouigours oui bien sûr mais si dans la
province la plus militarisée du pays un
habitant sur trois est lié de près ou de
loin à la police c'est quand même
enfin c'est quand même assez rare
d'avoir autant de pouvoir militaire sur
place
c'est ce qu'on a on a tous nos trucs
quand on est journaliste on va
effectivement dans les marchés de
kashgar comme voit dans le film on va
faire du chameau par exemple il ya des
promenades en chameau même là les guides
qui parle en anglais aux mamies qui
peuvent parler de manière discrète nous
ils nous disent attendant attention les
trois vieillards y en a un qui donne à
la police
donc il faut faire toujours très
attention effectivement ils sont il ya
des collaborateurs on va dire du régime
et donc ils ont toujours peur
effectivement leur parole est très
réservé ils ont très peur qu'est ce
qu'ils risquent
les ouigours a parlé quels sont les
risques pour eux en fait il s'agit pas
seulement des risques c'est une réalité
sur le terrain chauffeur s'il y a des
opposants si les activistes s'il ya des
militants s'il ya même des simples
enseignants qui parle dans leur langue
maternelle à leurs étudiants à l'école
il risque gros dans l'essence ou le y
défilent régime et les régimes sait très
bien comment prendre sa vengeance
donc ces gens là elles sont dans un
danger constant puisque non seulement
ils sont souvent sur écoute
mais il risque même leur intégrité
physique et cédera de temps dans la
prison arthur était de toute façon c'est
que je voulais dire parce que c'est lié
non seulement cette minorité là mais à
toute forme d'opposition en chine
le résine il sait très bien comment
faire taire ses opposants
toutes sortes de positions confondues
moi ce que j'aimerais comprendre c'est
quel est l'intérêt de la chine à avoir
annexé il ya plus de 70 ans
cette région jean luc domenach on entend
que effectivement il ya énormément de
ressources gaz pétrole charbon est ce
que c'est que ça vrai que c'est c'est
plus simple de répondre à la question
vous me posez quelques à la question
annexe muc comment comment expliquer le
choix tactique qui l'ont fait si vous
voulez ça c'est compliqué parce qu'on à
vide est idiot en revanche que là que le
cimt yang comme un peu comme le tibet
intéresse les dirigeants chinois
c'est clair tout ça stratégiquement
c'est important parce que c'est au
centre de 9 de l'asie économiquement
c'est important parce qu'il y a des
minerais culturellement c'est important
parce que c'est l'islam
et puis il ya aussi d'autres sujets
d'énervement qui dans le détail contre
pas mal le notamment il peut qu'ils
traitent bien leurs épouses et peut-être
même par exemple à la grande la grande
associes.com d'associer sur le grand
front de résistante de résistance et est
dirigé par une femme qui venait à paris
très souvent qu'ils étaient encore là il
ya quelque temps et je peux vous dire
qu'elle fait moi elle fait marcher son
nom d'un vraiment donc il ya aussi des
accès égalitaire salon vous serez vous
avez l'habitude la guiterne égalitaire
je ne sais pas mais en tout cas il y a
des il ne pèche pas par là où les
chinois pèse pas souvent des hommes
pêche - disons et puis aussi il y à
aussi l'énervement devant une culture
qui ce qui ce cliché qui tient bien une
culture robuste des ans
donc tout ça ça fait ça fait d' un refus
10 ans a produit un refus complet de de
ce qu'à mon avis aurait été possible
la preuve ils ont réussi à trouver des
trains des traîtres dans dix ans s'il
avait choisi une bonne tactique il
aurait trouvé probablement des amis et
pas seulement des traîtres et et là je
crois que c'est jamais une bonne une
bonne un bon choix une bonne solution
que de de choisir disons la brutalité la
violence les camps de travail
enfin ils ont laissé cette population a
subi disons toute la palette depuis le
début des camps de travail tout à
palette des ondes et des moyens de
répression et c'est affreux quoi
véritablement si le point de vue du
régime chinois il faut bien comprendre
qu'en chine on leur de pékin c'est celle
du rhône chi donc cette capitale de la
province du far west on est très loin de
plaisir il adressé la même heure et donc
pour les chinois c'est la chine
donc on dit nous les ouigours ils disent
ce sont des chinois oui c'est sur cette
minorité qui arrivent en masse dans
toutes ces provinces notamment et kiss
kiss qui dérange des ouigours puisqu'ils
disent qu'ils perdent leur culture que
tombe le vieux kashgar aujourd'hui qui
est complètement détruit par parce que
quand on va se le cacher on comprend que
la culture ouïgoure en prend un coup
ce qui fait peur aux chinois
effectivement c'est aussi des religions
ça leur a toujours fait peur est en tout
cas là
l'islam depuis 2002 puis 2011 c'était un
portage de radio free et j h pour à
l'époque il avait montré que les
ouigours disait en tout cas qu'ils
étaient contraints dans leur religion de
plus en plus notamment pour le voile par
exemple on voit on interdit aux femmes
de porter le voile fait raser la barbe
des hommes ont récréé coran selon les
préceptes communiste alors quand on va
avoir les académiciens donc proche du
régime l'académie des sciences sociales
du rhône qui vous disent oui mais vous
en france il ya plus de loi sur le voile
que chez eux encore mais cela 10 en
train de changer
effectivement il ya cesserait
restrictions qui arrivent de plus en
plus qui fâche qui font plus que ça qui
provoque la colère on voit que c'est
beaucoup de jeunes qui se rebellent
contre les contre la police chinoise
donc on il ya des incendies de
commissariats il ya des attaques des
institutions très très régulièrement
parce qu'il ya cette pression de plus en
plus sur l'islam
justement elle a l'oeil sur cette
question l'islam parce que je trouve
intéressant c'est que normalement dans
la constitution chinoise alors arrêtez
moi si je dis une bêtise c'est que
normalement on est en capacité on a le
droit d'exercer sa religion de manière
assez libre
la constitution chinoise dujail protège
les droits de l'homme a donc déjà n'ont
d'autre doit énoncer qui n'ont jamais
été respectées par les régimes donc on
est vraiment dans une contradiction qui
n'est pas particulièrement chinois selon
ça existe dans d'autres pays dans le
monde sait qui fait la différence dans
cette histoire c'est que moi je pense
que c'est aussi un élément de fierté
nationale de la chine qui englobe bien
évidemment les différentes minorités
mais qui au final ils se disent on va
vous assimilez parce que l on risque de
vous perdre sinon c'est le cas du tube
elle aux deux ouïghours et de l'autre
côté on va imposer une seule vision et
cette vachement important de le
souligner parce que des nouveaux s'est
passée le mans contre cette minorité
particulière
ça concerne toutes les autres minorités
et les chinois eux mêmes avant les
forces pro démocratiques
le régime communiste ou pseudo
communiste finalement ils essaient
d'imposer une seule vision unique de la
société du régime politique du pouvoir
de l'évolution de la chine
donc paris vraiment d'une élite qui
impose dans tout les reste du pays
sa vision des choses et veut justement
cette vision de la finalement sans qu
pas du tout et ça concerne pas du tout
le droit des nos mains alors justement à
ce propos
on avait donc dans ce documentaire un
touriste allemand qui ne venaient pas
pour la première fois dans la zone qui a
eu des mots assez impressionnant je
voudrais qu'on réécoute nos questions
commencent à mettre mal à l'aise les
guides mais nous ne sommes pas les seuls
dans le groupe a remarqué que tout ce
décor sonne faux l'un des rares européen
du voyage
un allemand qui connaît bien la région
c'est un également dans d'autres yeux
vous sourit dans un petit peu mais
maintenant ceci c'est assez fort quand
même c'est disneyland emmanuel qu'est ce
que ça veut dire en fait qu'on est ici
en train d'imaginer d'assimiler
complètement une population d'anéantir
une identité dans le documentaire on
parle de d'apartheid ethniques et
religieux c'est pas les mois un peu fort
écoutez quand j'étais responsable du
bureau asie d les filets h juste avant
le voilà de la fédération internationale
des ligues des droits de l'homme
j'ai été contacté en aide et contact est
la fille d achat a été contacté par deux
chez les chiites
la déclaration des dalaï lama qui
parlait à l'époque du génocide culturel
c'était l'époque où l'opposition dit
vettel elle voulait justement profiter
de l'attention médiatique si vous voulez
sur la chine le saison hippique qui
s'approchait etc pour faire entendre la
voix des tibétains la répression plus
subi sept ans on se souvient tous des
événements en mars 2008 et se doit donc
de les lamas il a parlé d une au site
culturel ce qui n'est pas tout à fait
une notion accepté dans le cadre du
droit international puisqu'il est droit
international il parle de génocide en
d'autres termes est pas en terminale et
qu'il éclaire tueur de protection de la
culture mais pratiquement parlant il
s'agit des seins parce que non seulement
ils changent la composition de la
population sur place
à titre informatif à l'est
eliane donc qui viennent s'installer
représente aujourd'hui 40% de la
population tout à fait nommer une
session des chiffres et qui change des
décennies après une idée façon quand
même impressionnante pour ne pas dire
terrifiante
finalement non seulement donc ils
changent la composition de la population
sur place mais il impose un modèle des
cultures qui respectent pas du tout la
particularité de la région ni de la
minorité et sa des nouveaux c'est pas
seulement les zoulous route mettant mais
ça concerne aussi d'autres minorités et
les régimes et il est l'emploi une
stratégie qui l'a très bien élaboré
d'ailleurs un pack les rate tout al'air
peut-être mais c'est la même stratégie
au niveau national et local ou
international
juste une parenthèse comme aux dires de
densifier encore ce que vous voulez dire
qui est très très juste on oublie
souvent de me citer les manipulations
des autres minorités nationales et
notamment de toutes les minorités
musulmanes le régime comme souvent les
colonisateurs des on a joué à plusieurs
plusieurs reprises les les minorités
minoritaire si je peux dire par rapport
à la grosse maj une majorité qui donne
en train de devenir une grosse minorité
et il faut reconnaître que ce qui se
passe au tilt ce que les musulmans à
l'attitude des musulmans au tibet comme
hôte sinkiang je crois c'est pas
vraiment ce dont ils seront le plus fier
plus tard on parlait du vieux kachkar et
de disneyland moi je dirais que toute la
chine comme un bon modéré cela toute la
chine malheureusement ressemble à
disneyland aujourd'hui c'est pas
simplement dans les territoires repris
mais que cela se passe là
malheureusement la culture chinoise est
aussi anne est abîmée dans plein
d'endroits on conserve les villes et
donc la destruction est partout on est
dans une phase de mondialisation la
chine qui fait que de toute façon
l'identité chinoise est en train de se
faire vous voyez ce qu'ils font sur les
plateaux tibétains c'est à dire des
lotissements tout à fait joli hein on
peut presque dormir sur la route
tellement ses propres ils font des
jolies lotissement mais ça casse
complètement la culture nomade tibet
mais pour le régime chinois s'est donnée
la civilisation aux gens et c'est
vraiment il le pense c'est le but en
fait
c'était là tout est donc évidemment que
ça casse les modes de vie mais ça ils
l'ont fait partout dans toute la chine
ce n'est pas seulement réservé au web
gourin il faut quand même comprendre
cela le disney moi je dis disneyland
c'est dans toute la chine
d'accord ces quartiers refait un peu
promenade un peu voilà la différence
c'est que beaucoup de chinois de chine
se laisse disney is et périls mais on
dira alors que les tb des tibétains et
les minorités musulmanes de du think ne
veulent pas c'est cet autre la
différence alors oui mais les rues et
par exemple c'est vrai que ça se passe
beaucoup mieux pour les musulmans par
exemple qu'on retrouve dans d'autres
provinces qui n'ont pas du tout ces
problèmes là en tout cas vive sont des
commerçants sont très bien on boit
beaucoup de mariages mixtes enfin ça se
passe beaucoup mieux mais c'est vrai que
là on a on a une les gars ses
cabinets et les ouigours ne se sentent
complètement spoliés de leur culte mais
là en fait c'est quoi c'est parce que
les ouigours son turcophone parce qu'à
la base ce ne font pas du tout des
chinois ceci vous me dites qu'il ya des
minorités musulmanes pour qu'il n'y a
pas de problème qui a les mariages
mixtes etc
j'entends que du coup ces lettres la
question turcophones qui se pose c'est
leur attachement à l'asie centrale c'est
quoi mais c'est surtout que les ouigours
se sentent chez eux et qu'ils estiment
que les chiens eux ne sont pas chez eux
à eybens et sanaa le 3 juin
alors en plus bien évidemment de
commander la question de l'élection et
la colère suite à des différences de
coutume il ya des différences etc mais
le point central c'est que une série de
minorités nationales dont la plus
importante la minorité ouïghoure ils
disent ici on est chez nous et les
menées chez le chinois depuis déjà
d'ailleurs très très longtemps dit je
vous croyez vous êtes chez vous mais
c'est nous qui sommes chez nous parce
que nous sommes les plus forts la même
chose chez les tibétains il ya notre
correspondante razia liste sur le site
d'information asélistes c'est sylvie
lasserre quine des meilleurs
spécialistes de la région a écrit un
livre justement sur cette culture
ouigours et on voit tout à fait que
c'est complètement différente même de la
culture and côte vous écoutez les cotes
vous allez vous dans ces longs trains
pour aller pour un petit peu
discrètement comme vous vous rendez au
xinjiang comme on l'a fait vous parlez
avec les ânes
ils sont dans les trains et les vous
dise oui mais ce sont des regroupements
de jeunes en impressionnant qui parle
des banlieues
son temps de jeu ils cassent tout voilà
comme ils décrivent les ouigours donc
une vraie différence culturelle entre
les deux populations on voit qu'il ya
aussi une forme emmanuel de
discriminations quasi institutionnalisée
les les meilleurs emplois vont aux ânes
y compris dans cette province
ils n'ont pas accès à l'emploi de
manière logique automatique comme ils
pourraient y prétendre
c'est une volonté à votre avis de pékin
de vouloir mettre en place sa forme de
discrimination cette différenciation des
taux d'inflation de 2 ha pour compléter
si vous me permettez un élément qui est
quand même très important c'est que les
ouïgours rêvant dit quand même leur
droit à l'autodétermination
c'est vachement important par rapport à
d'autres minorités religieuses ou etc
n'est pas le cas dans d'autres minorités
pas toujours de l'état et dans d'autres
minorités donc ces versions important il
considère que c'est une partie de leur
territoire qui est annexé par la chine
dans les années 50 et qui est donc il
est proclame ses droits même à devant
les instances internationales en faisant
leur lobby international etc
c'est pour ça d'ailleurs qu'il y ait un
rôle qu'on veut goal com qu'en grèce
comme on dit en anglais et à l'autre
élément qui se voudrait justement
compléter ces qui les régimes finalement
il fait la même chose dont il accuse les
occidentaux et quand on parle de droits
de l'homme et qui les forces entre
guillemets occidental où les états
européens ou américains ou australie
autre pari des droits de l'homme en
chine
les régimes répond mais vous n'avez pas
les droits c'est la vision occidentale
la vision globalisé des droits de
l'homme
ici on est chez nous et c est on voit
que dans l'intérieur du pays
ils sont exactement de faire exactement
la même chose et d'ailleurs sans prendre
aucune mesure des précautions si vous
voulez parce que c'est là où ils sont
pas mal hein si vous voulez vraiment
imposer un ordre la paix ou la
prospérité dans ces régions il aurait
essayé quand même un minimum à respecter
un minimum les acquis sociaux la culture
locale faire promouvoir peut-être un
équilibre entre l'exercice d'une eia
religion et de rapports de domination
qui fait que l'on veut anéantir une
identité de telle sorte à légitimer
prise de pouvoir sur un territoire où tu
as failli il arrive avec syrte où de
moyens de violence violence policière
violence institutionnelle
discriminations institutionnelles et
qu'ils imposent effectivement et ses
changements dans les mers dans la
mentalité dans la culture dans
l'éducation à l'emploi dans les
développements main financier cela
s'ajoute aussi zhang au tibet comme et
après les beaucoup de colonies dans le
monde
ce que j'appellerais la manipulation
linguistique c'est à dire que le
colonisateur ou l'occupant impose sa
langue créée une une classe sociale
qu'une femme dont il favorise les
activités économiques et ensuite la
population locale se trouve devant la
danse devant un choix qui était horrible
soit 2,2 d'entrée linguistiquement et
socialement dans la dent clients des
terres des traîtres si je peux dire soit
au contraire à l'ordre de refuser la de
refuser la modernisation linguistique et
à ce moment là on ne devient incapable
de se servir de certains de certains
moyens de défense le maire j'en ai parlé
à de très hauts responsables le tibétain
j'en ai parlé également à la dirigeante
de 2,7 de ce front de libération et j'ai
jamais entendu de réponse totalement
satisfaisante parce que le plus fort
quand il sait quand il est en même temps
le plus fort politique et militaire
quand il est en même temps le plus fort
économique et qu' ils trouvent et le
plus fort sociale c'est-à-dire qu'ils
trouvent beauce eeb il a la possibilité
d' amalgame est une une clé une couche
sociale les minorités prêtresse plus que
ceux qui veulent faire du fric oui se
trouve très trésor alors justement à ce
propos on avait vu dans le documentaire
une jeune femme institutrice qui
revenait sur son expérience de
l'apprentissage de la langue à ses
élèves j'ai grandi au milieu d'eux je
croyais que le parti nous avait libérés
n'était là que pour nous aider c'était
un lavage de cerveau
on était juste bon qu'à obéir ce n'est
qu'après les émeutes de juillet 2009 que
j'ai compris que nous n'étions pas des
chinois part entière à l'époque j'étais
institutrice le proviseur de l'école a
réuni tous les professeurs ouïghours les
ouigours où il n'est que des moustiques
n'oubliez jamais été d'une seule main
vous brisez on va vous brisez d'une
seule main comme des moustiques c'est
extrêmement fort ce témoignage
moi ce que je comprends dans ce
témoignage c'est que ça ça aussi
consolider les actions dites terroristes
fin du mois de qualifier de terrorisme
par la chine
ce qu'il faut savoir c'est que les
ouigours aujourd'hui donc on a des
fronts qui se font mis en place il ya
une forme de terrorisme un peu du moins
c'est la manière dont la chine ne
qualifie stéphane lagarde quand vous
entendez ça finalement c'est un peu
logique que ça et consolider en front
antichinois en titane 2009au faut
vraiment comprendre une fracture
terrible ya les émeutes les windsor qui
se rebellent et on voit les images
d'ailleurs les la propagande chinoise va
les utiliser parce qu'il ya des
violences commis courant sur les années
les violences terribles via cette
rébellion et la ja la répression une
chape de plomb comme on a rarement vu
dans le monde
un an sans internet a qu'un territoire
qui est trois fois grand comme la france
pas d'internet la plupart des anglo
saxons qui travaillait à cette époque là
qu'ont été en 2009 couvrir ces émeutes
avec des des traducteurs m'ont dit
quasiment tous ils ont fait un jour ans
étaient réunis ils ont dit presque tous
nos fixeur ce qu'on appelle les fixeurs
dans les journalistes à dire des
traducteurs qui guide qui aident à faire
les interviews les ouigours sont tous en
prison
ils ont pris un à dix ans de prison moi
j'ai vu avant qu'il soit emprisonné
ilham tohti qu'un grand professeur
ouigours qui était à pékin qu'il
complètement modéré qui lui prenait pas
du tout l'autodétermination des ouigours
me voulait au contraire essayer
d'arranger les choses il a été enfermé
on à la dernière fois je les ai vus on
était dans un parc à pékin n'était
suivie par cette personne il fallait
arracher sans arrêt
il a été arrêté trois jours après il a
pris 10 ans prison raisin pressé
vraiment évident la répression donc
c'est une fracture énorme qui fait
qu'aujourd'hui effectivement après on a
vu après 2009 petit à petit 2010 2011 on
a vu des attaques contre les
commissariats encore une fois et puis
surtout des gens alors dans le
documentaire andy 4000km crois que ces
deux mises entre entre rome et pékin
des gens qui prennent une jeep alors ils
ont dit une jeep ça peut être un 4 4 et
qui prennent avec des bidons d'essence
qui vont se faire exploser
oui ce cas tiananmen donc ça crée aussi
ce que les attaques terroristes ayant du
sens parce qu'on voit bien qu'il ya pas
non plus énormément de capacités
d'organisation si vous me dites qu'on
utilise des voitures béliers qu'on fait
des attaques au couteau pendant un
moment c'est dommage à la changer
la propagande chinoise des fois un petit
peu de charme entre guillemets je suis
donc de dire ça mais il y avait une
personne qui était formidable une dame
de la propagande chinoise
quand on l'appelait ont la haine de dida
l'on dit rien attentats oui encore un
attentat c'est terrible comment ça s'est
passé alors il avait trois couteaux à
melon à un couteau à un pastèque et
préciser tout donc voyez c'était du
terrorisme rigoureux
ok donc mon cette personne a été changé
maintenant ils ont changé de discours
mais à l'époque quand nous on avait des
informations sur les attentats c'était à
chaque fois au couteau à steak quand
même jean luc domenach
à ce propos on peut entendre aussi que
la chine soutient contre le terrorisme
intérieur d'autant que ce sont des
musulmans dont on parle oui bon l'élite
le terrorisme islamique est quand même
de la petite bière par rapport le
problème chinois et c'est quand même de
la petite bière par rapport à bien
d'autres problèmes qui se posent en
occident ou au moyen-orient afin d'une
part mais ce qui est vrai et qui
explique aussi la fureur des chinois
c'est ce que j'appellerais l'efficacité
meurtrière de ces groupes de désespérer
quand même quelque chose
d'extraordinaire
quand vous quand vous je reprends ce que
disait mon voisin quand vous mettez côte
à côte les armes qu'ils avaient et les
effets je crois que on a peu vu
vu dans l'histoire des batailles une
telle efficacité de du labat de bois
dizaines de morts alors après dans
l'autre sens ça qu'on voit que c'est une
forme d'action qui est tourné vers
l'extérieur en ce qui concerne les
ouigours les tibétains s'immole donc par
le feu plus globalement m nl
on voit qu'il ya des disparus il ya des
immolations donc au tibet il ya des
actions dites terroristes un qualifié de
terroriste dans cette province
comment est-ce que vous quelle est votre
lecture de cette question comment est ce
que le gouvernement chinois finalement a
mis en place une forme de répression
vous qui avez mené la campagne pour
l'outil a hobo et sa femme est ce qu'il
ya en pas encore plus de difficultés à
être opposant aujourd'hui au régiment de
toute façon du régime il a durci son ton
est plus jolie pique ça a été un grand
succès c'était la grande fierté chez
marc valat tout à fait et de toute façon
et maintenant il est plus consolidée
dans son pouvoir
il a mené des campagnes de répression
contre les suspects civile les
activistes des droits de l'homme les
avocats des droits des landes
les activistes avaient pour la
protection de l'environnement même les
féministes et ses rites et des rats tout
le monde est en prison tout le monde
peut disparaître tout le monde et rend
détention arbitraire tout le monde
risquent la torture
wisques est tout simplement en chine on
n'a pas le droit de parler il vraiment
on n'a pas le droit d'écrire c'est qu'on
veut on n'a pas la liberté des médias
on n'a pas la liberté d'information on a
une liberté chiffres 2013 de sfr la
chine occupe la 173e position sur 179 la
liberté de la presse
non mais c'est vraiment dramatique parce
qu'ils remplissent on devait non à
l'extérieur de la chine est là j'aurai
un discours qui qui qui sera pas du tout
provocateur combler régime chinois en
ont parlé des activistes occidentaux ou
internationaux soit nous on n'a jamais
dit on vient en chine pour vous
apprendre le modèle de la démocratie
europe 1
les vidéastes on est international rsf
qui me lie tout pour mon solidarité
chine
tout le monde disait nous on est là pour
soutenir la société civile chinoise
nous on est là pour soutenir réussi à
vous avocats chinois
on est là pour faire entendre leur voix
puisqu'il le régime
justement muselle tous ces gens là et
les faits disparaîtront et c'est
intéressant des paris aussi des
disparitions forcées
c'est pas seulement de la détention
arbitraire c'est pas seulement l'anglais
moment où la condamnation à cinq coups à
10 ans de prison
oui c'est aussi le fait qu'ils font
disparaître les gens et qui après
quelques jours semaines mois on découvre
que finalement ils ont été détenus dans
un tel comme servia dans un tel combat
je rappelle ses prix nobel de la paix
2010 il est emprisonné depuis 2008 sa
femme est sous résidence
l'histoire des lieux xiabo il est
vraiment très représentatif pas ce qui
est à la base c'est un intellectuel
c'était pas du tout un activiste ou en
2008 on a des droits de l'homme ou un
avocat etc et il a vraiment fait en
sorte dé réunir si vous voulez l'élite
intellectuelle les gens qui voulaient
avoir une autre vision
il a demandé avec la charte 2008 avec
d'autres opposants et activistes chinois
plus de démocratie il s'est retrouvé
derrière les barreaux mais ce qui est
dramatique c'est pas lui qui a pris le
risque en sachant les dangers qui ces
risques c'était liberté de réflexion en
cours et la hausse depuis le début de
cette campagne connaît qu'on a commencé
avec les différents prix nobel de la
paix notamment shirin ebadi mais avec le
soutien d'autres prix nobel de la paix
et le plusieurs le plusieurs
associations de la société civile
associations des droits de l'homme ccift
où sa femme
ouais donc il tient kyi assignée à
résidence qui est dans un état
psychologique très très grave
elle a été un danger plusieurs fois
c'est une artiste c'est un intellectuel
c'est une photographe elle n'a jamais
pris une position politique c'est sa
femme justement
donc là on part vraiment d'une
discrimination et à une violation des
droits de la dignité de la personne
ouais vraiment dramatique activement à
lyon peut pas aller la voir à pékin moi
j'ai essayé plusieurs fois et à chaque
fois on s'est fait arrêter par les
gardiens qui l'entourent donc elle est
assignée à résidence là c'est comme une
prison elle a pas loin de sortir comme
beaucoup moi je voulais revenir sur ce
que vous disiez tout à l'heure c'est
vrai qu'aujourd'hui avec she jean ping
qui est l'homme le plus fort de chine je
parte il aussi pour que des cherpines ya
c'est quelqu'un qui a quasiment la plus
voir de mao et on constate pardon je
vous confie une minute c'est que le
bilan son bilan est déjà catastrophique
en matière de droits de l'homme c'est à
dire que 2014 a été la pire année
quand on vit public et qu'on est
journaliste on voit effectivement ça
s'est considérablement dégradée pour
tout ce qui est acteur civiles les
avocats comme bush qui hantent des
grands avocats
tout le monde a été arrêtée pas
simplement les intellectuels ceux qui
sont entre guillemets marqué comme
dissident mais beaucoup ont été arrêtés
interdits parler il y avait un moment on
parle de la charte 08 la caq a lancé liu
xiaobo donc c'est une charte
d'intellectuels un peu court sur le
modèle des pays de l'est de vaclav havel
des intellectuels qui disent respecter
la constitution chinoise les libertés
parce que la constitution chinoise je
pense que c'est la meilleure au monde un
agent le papier mais voilà respecter
cela tous ces personnes ont été arrêtées
après il ya eu les aa les avocats même
les artistes aujourd'hui on perd un
écrivain comme mules john shen qui va
passer en france bientôt disait moi j'ai
peur d'être arrêtée à tout moment un
écrivain de romans donc on ça c'est
vraiment dur s'ils y avait aussi des
repas qui était organisée entre citoyens
des justes des repas citoyen un
mouvement qui a été complètement aussi
l'a miné il ya deux ans donc
effectivement c'est une répression
terrible je n'ai pas de graves
divergences avec ce tableau mais je
voudrais le le nuancer dans les deux
sens dans le sens du pirée dans le sens
du du un peu mieux ce que le poids le
propos de mon voisin mais j'ai peut-être
tort alors dans le sens dans le sens de
du pire
il y a je dirais maintenant quasiment
une théorie de l'oppression de
l'oppression nationale c'est à dire est
une théorie de l'oppression nationale
est impérial c'est clair maintenant que
ce itunes ping est le meilleur depuis
depuis taxe européenne et peut-être même
encore meilleur comme comme dirigeants
de la chine
en gros général et que du coup celui ci
concentre le pouvoir et il a une
politique qui qui englobe à la fois
l'intérieur et l'extérieur à la fois il
flagelle les les vietnamiens on calme le
but un peu brutalement l'est de taiwan
et les japonais il joue avec les accès
avec eux avec poutine de façon de
l'hégire or ce qu'ils veulent de petites
le monde du poker
il donne un peu leur voix etc aucun
intérêt ils s'en foutent
il peut y trouver dans cette histoire
c'est le puissant et il est vraiment une
politique impériale alors ça c'est c'est
cela va légitimer de plus en plus de une
dureté extrême dans toutes les zones de
minorité nationale et sont visés par
selon les ouigours pas selon les
tibétains
mais il ya aussi des zones
dans le sud ouest où il ya des tailles
etc etc
donc ça c'est là la première chose alors
est par ailleurs en même temps il ya
aussi du meilleur bas parfois un peu
paradoxal comme il l'a fait pour une
peau d'être populaire et parce qu'il
pense que pour pouvoir cogner il faut
avoir une administration sur laquelle on
compte qu'on tient bien
alors maintenant la corruption il
supporte plus au moins il se fait pas
d'illusion pour la suite
là je suis d'accord sur le pouvoir de
ces jean ping et surtout l'affluence
pillay qui fait rayonner la chine si on
prend la route de la soie la fameuse
route de la soie c'est surtout de la
route des hydrocarbures
et ça marche diplomatiquement puisque
l'indonésie tout le monde rejoint ce
plan là simplement non quand il fait là
le plan anti corruption c'est vrai
qu'une des choses qui choque le plus la
population chinoise c'est la justice et
la justice c'est quand on doit aller à
l'école donner une cartouche de
cigarettes au directeur de l'école pour
pouvoir entrer dans l'école
c'est toute cette corruption qui va pas
simplement au niveau comme il dit les
tigres et les mouchards amis pour pour
qu' il se fait aucune illusion il est
totalement cynique et la corruption le
dell va recommencer bien sûr plus de 7
ce qui tient sa demande il faut vite
cher donc chaque fonctionnaire à un
dossier rouge et un blanc et donc qu'on
sort le mauvais quand il faut le faire
tomber tout ça on voit surtout dans
cette affaire de corruption c'est qui
fait tomber ses rivaux c'est là encore
une fois on chez jean ping a talent
politique extraordinaire et qu'il est
très fort me l'a fait tomber
zhou yongkang tout le clan ou encore un
peu comme les jivaros en alerte les
têtes
ouais on fait tomber toute la famille
autour et puis petit à petit ça remonte
c'est quand même la corse et le plan
anti corruption n'est pas que
comprennent qu'ils ont très rapidement
c'est simplement pour dire que en même
temps à une catégorie de la population
dont les le droit à manifester
concrètement c'est des étendues c'est
les gens des villes
on est quand même dans les gens des
villes se fâche qui manifestent contre
une contre une installation chimiques ou
un truc comme ça alors là la police le
garde parce que ça
cela veut dire si ça peut toucher aussi
le début de couches sociales de couches
sociales urbaines qui achètent des
déchets les ouigours ça il ya quelque
chose qu'il faut survivre voilà alors
moi ce qui m'interroge
à ce propos c'est que autant en 2008 sur
le passage de la flamme olympique à
paris on avait eu énormément
d'activistes des militants qui s'étaient
battus qui avait fait émerger cette
question des droits de l'homme enfin la
question des droits de l'homme en chine
a quand même été extrêmement présente
dans la scène médiatique dans la scène
politique
j'ai quand même le sentiment qu'elle a
totalement disparu depuis quelques
années et j'ai souvenir lors du passage
justement du président chinois l'année
dernière en mars 2014
pendant quatre jours pour une visite
d'état que la france s'était couvert de
tous les oripeaux de la civilisation
chinoise la circulation avait été arrêté
reçu en grande pompe
est-ce qu'on a changé de visage est-ce
qu'on a changé de comportement vis-à-vis
de la sinne la crise économique
effectivement l'europe maintenant fait
des pieds et des mains pour rentrer en
chine pour les marchés et vous avez ce
qu'on appelle la diplomatie économique
en tout cas c'est comme ça que l'appel
manuel valls qui fait qu'on se courbe à
chaque fois vouliez cameron par exemple
pour l'histoire c'est pareil pour
l'angleterre qu'à me rendre l'autre jour
qui donne quinze jours de visa et weiwei
l'artiste ai weiwei parce que chez jean
ping va arriver le président chinois
faut surtout pas que l'artiste dissident
rencontre dont qui donne au début ça
fait un tollé international et finissent
par lui donner six mois aujourd'hui à
que l'allemagne effectivement qui à
cette politique qui donne six mois de
visa par exemple l'arrivée oui sans
problème
l'allemagne est la seule en europe à
aujourd'hui aller visiter quand ils
écoutaient anglais
je pense qu'on comprend souvent mal les
chinois clé les français les connaissent
mal les anglais aussi et qu'il faut
comprendre aussi le régime chinois n'ont
pas danser dans l'abjection et dans la
répression
mais il est très mal compris et donc il
faut être ferme avec eux on peut on ne
peut pas changer tout le temps il ya une
marionnette changer tout le temps si on
est ferme avec la chine
ils comprennent en tout cas vite le
climat est aux affaires à faire après
avoir été nous rend plus on a lu
l'héritage gaulliste
les relations du domaine c'est plus
malin que ça je vous dire le détail de
l'art delà de la réconciliation
franco-chinoise extraordinaire ils ont
payé tout jusque rubis sur l'ongle
chinois ils ont été à l'hôtel ils n'ont
pas récupéré leur de boules étaient
beaucoup plus dur dans le détail mais
les gaullistes derrière ont au contraire
se raconter un roman alors à leurs
diplomates qui nous dont certains
continuent d'ailleurs à dire mais la
france et la chine sont faites pour
s'aimer pour ce tout un roman absolument
insupportable
en fait comme la france en fait pour ça
mais on ne peut pas dire à notre frère
chinois que de droits de l'homme c'est
important de suivre vraiment quelques
principes des bases mais qui sont
vraiment fondamental pour la paix et la
stabilité mondiales
donc il s'agit bas c'est le monde où la
chine ou de l'inde ou de la birmanie ou
du soudan sans qu'on parle des
l'universalité des droits de l'homme
c'est vachement important de les
censurer s'applique à tous les êtres
humains dans tous les pays
dans n'importe quelle circonstance donc
moi je pense à tanguer et si vous voulez
plus un de national ou étranger pas
vraiment pas français je pense que c'est
pas seulement un problème de la france
où deux des royaumes unis
c'était vraiment un problème de l'union
européenne comment d'autres cas et dans
d'autres affaires et l'union européenne
elle n'a pas su elle n'a pas pu et il
n'a pas appris à parler avec une seule
langue au régime chinois comme dans
d'autres régions
ce que je comprends en creux c'est que
les états unis par exemple sont en
capacité d'avoir sept rapports je pense
qu'elle est monde aujourd'hui il est un
peu perdu notamment parce que le modèle
chinois
finalement sur la scène internationale
c'est un modèle réussi déjà et pas
seulement sur les plantes et
financier et économique développement et
aidera mais leur diplomatie aussi dans
les instances internationales
leur propagande au niveau international
elle est tellement bien élaborée elle
est tellement bien préparés qui
aujourd'hui on est en train de se poser
la question si finalement les activistes
ils disent la vérité ou pas aussi tous
ces instituts universitaires qu'on les
appelle conçu aux financés par le régime
dans d'autres universités étrangères
elles sont aussi réussi que la
propagande et du régime
derrière du pays donc on est un peu
perplexe parce que finalement on sais
pas avec quoi on a affaire en face oui
la france et la chine sont fait poursuit
mais moi je suis désolé moi je trouve
que effectivement ces deux civilisations
passionnante et qu'on a évidemment à se
rencontrer à se voir et on le fait
d'ailleurs le problème c'est
effectivement les droits de l'homme - ya
20 ans j'étais correspondre en corée du
sud la corée du sud qui est une
démocratie qui était depuis au moins
plus de 10 ans déjà entrées dans le
système d'élection universel tous et à
l'époque on me disait ah nan nan mais
nous on peut pas être comme vous pour
les droits de l'homme nous on a les
valeurs asiatiques
aujourd'hui vous dites ça une table à
séoul on vous dit vous êtes raciste ou
quoi mais je suis asiatique j'ai le
droit aux ovins grand asiatique en chine
encore certains disent encore sa non les
différentes vous sur le plan des droits
de l'homme ce n'est absolument pas vrai
aujourd'hui les chinois font du mal aux
chinois et pas au reste du monde je
trouve surtout aux chinois c'est ça qui
est dramatique mais sinon moi je suis
pour que la france et la chine sait mais
évidemment pas question en revanche moi
j'aimerais qu'on réfléchisse on a encore
quelques minutes sur la position en tant
que puissance régionale et
internationale de la chine
aujourd'hui on ne peut pas non plus se
poser en tant qu occident en donneur de
leçons à un pays qui a une civilisation
comme celle ci qui a comme vous le
disiez manuel une forme de soft power en
termes diplomatiques c'est à dire de une
forme de diplomatie en fait qui n'est
pas à celle de l'occident et qui ne
cherchent pas forcément à imposer des
valeurs des codes etc mais qui pour
autant en fait est un des premiers
partenaires commerciaux que ce soit de
l'europe et a fortiori je pense à
l'afrique aujourd'hui c'est le premier
par le premier partenaire commercial
alors est ce qu'il n'ya pas aussi une
autre forme de diplomatie
deux valeurs qui peuvent s'imposer votre
adresse
d'abord la la politique étrangère
chinoise est une politique c'est vrai
bien bien combiner mais qui rencontrent
autant d'heureux d'obstacles que toutes
les autres avaient tous les autres
toutes les autres grandes puissances ne
vous parler de l'afrique
je m'attends les pays africains
commencent à revenir en arrière et pour
citer un épisode plaisant après la fin
d'une dune d'une discussion qui aurait
été souvent m'a terriblement pessimiste
et ben helli shiloh commis une erreur
terrible et donc ils ont apporté leur
propre presque prostituées c'est
exactement la bêtise qu'il fallait pas
faire et donc qui fait l'opinion
publique dans une capitale africaine
ben voilà c'est donc ça barde dans
toutes les pièces des places centrales
d'afrique etc
d'autre part les hommes d'affaires etc
sont pas toujours content il ya aussi la
politique impériale menée sur le sur les
bords de la chine le japon le vietnam et
au fond les décideurs font la bêtise
qu'aux fêtes vous bien d'eux des
empereurs et bien des tirs en avant qui
est d'abord de s'occuper de ceux qui
veulent qu'ils sont les moins capables
de mettre le holà lorrain période ces
derniers voisins en général les voisins
de quelqu'un qui devient très fort tous
et ce et se prépare à se défendre et
c'est alors ajouté que vous avez le
vietnam à côté je prends pas un grand
risque en disant que levier table est
l'état nation ce qu'ils sont ils sont
pas toujours bons partout sauf pour
faire la guerre et donc n'oubliez pas il
y aura du sport un vrai problème alors
pour l'afrique
effectivement on voit lors de la
dernière tournée africaine jean ping le
président chinois on a vu des banquiers
en afrique à lagos où ailleurs dire
attention ne veut plus de l'échangé
inégal
celle là elle fait plus maintenant vos
prêts nous construire les rails et tout
c'est vrai que c'était que les chinois
qui pouvait faire ça à construire des
routes magnifiques et puis rennes non ça
ne suffit plus maintenant on voudrait
nous aussi pouvoir avoir un échange nous
développer c'est plus si simple que ça
le problème puisque nous répondent les
chinois souvent en tout cas le
gouvernement chinois c'est qu'on
voudrait souvent que la chine ne fasse
pas les erreurs de l'occident ne
colonise par la spa tout ça c'est ce
qu'on leur demande aux chinois
effectivement donc c'est une position
qui est délicate notamment sur le plan
des droits de l'homme on en dit surtout
ne faites pas ce qu'on a fait nous c'est
à dire aller coloniser les autres pays
où tout ça pour profiter avant tout je
veux dire vous avez parlé tout à l'heure
du partenariat économique avec avec
plusieurs états d'afrique
en fait c'est pas tout à fait un
partenariat les chinois ils étaient là
pour exploiter davantage sont importants
mais pour revenir sur la politique
internationale de la chine qui est
vachement importante puisqu'elle est
membre du conseil de sécurité et qu'on a
vu tous les nombres des résolutions qui
l'a bloqué en exerçant son droit au veto
effectivement cette cette politique là
aujourd'hui dont l'état actuel du monde
elle est catastrophique
oui puisque hinglo qu'on les aide les
interventions syrie à gauche ou à droite
comme il l'a fait avec la birmanie
eh ben on voit tout le soutien de la
communauté internationale au régime ou
au changement démocratique dont le monde
soutient absolument besoin de moi je me
souviens que j'étais pour revenir sur le
xinjiang compte il était on m'a dit ça
soit dans les cimetières musulmans pour
semer la police n'y vont pas soit au
grand marché
j'ai été jusqu'au vespasiennes jusqu'aux
toilettes et là j'étais suivie jusqu'aux
par un âne devoir on le remarque
jusqu'aux toilettes pour vous dire que
oui il sert encore c'est un état qui est
totalitaire qui surveille tout le monde
et on arrive à une première puissance
économique mondiale ses mains
ce sera la première fois dans l'histoire
où on a ça donc il faut quand même très
fort diplomatiquement et leur dire
attention sur le plan des droits de
l'homme allez-y mollo et bien écoutez ce
sera le mot de la fin merci à vous tous
d'avoir participé à ce débat vous pouvez
bien entendu nous envoyer des mails sur
l'adresse mail de l'émission et
je ne vous retrouve pas la semaine
prochaine vous avez rendez vous avec
bénédicte le chatelier chao à bientôt